من يصل اليها اولا هو السؤال المريح بعد
ان سقطت او اسقطت طائره امريكيه مسيره
للاستطلاع من طراز امبيو 9 في البحر
الاسود اشارت مصادر الى ان سقوطها كان على
بعد نحو 70 كيلومترا جنوب غرب شبه جزيره
القرم بعد ان انطلقت من احدى قواعد النيتو
في المنطقه واقتربت من المياه والاجواء
الدوليه سكرتير مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
نيكولاي باتروشيف اعتبر انتشار موسكو
لحطام المسير امرا ضروريا وقال ان لدى
بلاده امكانيه تقنيه لانتشال الحطام وجاء
في تقرير لشبكه يور نيوز عن مسؤولين
وخبراء عسكريين امريكيين انه من الواضح ان
البيت الابيض يفضل الا تقع هذه
التكنولوجيا الحساسه في ايدي الكرملين
شبكه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه نقلت عن
خبراء بدا عمليه استعاده حطام الطائره
لكنهم قالوا ان البحريه الروسيه بامكانها
الوصول الى الحطام قبل اي سفينه امريكيه
فقد تداولت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تسجيلات صوتيه قالت انها لعمليه اطلقتها
القوات الروسيه لاستعاده الطائره التي
يعتقد انها مجهزه بتقنيات تجسس متطوره
عاده وتخضع عمليه الانتشار الى جمله عوامل
وفق خبراء بينها المعاينه اولا ثم تحديد
العمق الذي توجد فيه المسيره واحداثيات
دقيقه للموقع وارسال فريق غطس متخصص كي لا
يتم الاضرار بالطائره ويستهدف البحث
والانتشار بالاساس التاكد ان بقيه المسيره
جسما واحدا او سيتعلق الامر بانتشاد اجزاء
المتفرقه وموضع الكاميرات الدقيقه
الموجوده بها يفسر خبراء مصارعه موسكو
لانتشار حطام المسيره لتسجيل ما يمكن وصفه
بالنصر المعنوي ويتحدثون عما يعرف
بالهندسه العكسيه لاعاده الانتاج وهو امر
مستبعد او على الاقل معرفه خصائصها
الدقيقه وماذا التقطت اذا لم تتضرر ولانها
سقطت في البحر الاسود فقد قال وزير الدفاع
التركي بشان امكانيه فتح البحر الاسود
للسفن الحربيه الامريكيه ان تركيا باشرت
اتصالات مستمره مع الاطراف كلها لحل
الازمه وللتذكير فمسيره
متطوره تجعل الجيش الامريكي يعتمد عليها
في العمليات العسكريه وتصل سرعتها الى نحو
370 كيلومترا في الساعه لطائره متعدده
المهام المزوده بمعدات رصد بالليزر قدره
على اطلاق سته صواريخ وقنابل بدقه عاليه
وبوسعها ان تحلق لمسافه تزيد عن 1500 كم
او لمده تصل الى اكثر من 30 ساعه وبما
انها طائره من دون طيار فمن الطبيعي ان
فريقا على الارض هو الذي يتحكم بعملها
[موسيقى]